welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is episode
37 with marion toopey marion toopey is
co-author of this delightfully positive
book
10 global trends every smart person
should know
he's a senior policy analyst at the
cato's institute center for global
liberty and prosperity
and the lead editor at the incredibly
popular humanprogress.org
if you haven't followed human progress
on twitter you should
it's a positive account devoted to the
accurate representation of global trends
for instance global happiness
is rising it's a very cool tabletop
like living room book i would recommend
it
this episode is brought to you by marty
creative
co i have their beautiful leather
journal
and i'm waiting to grab some of their
other products like folios cup holders
you can get whatever you want on their
website engraved by using the code
mp i'm actually going to get a journal
and engrave my lion logo
on it so that's kind of fun it's a great
option for
christmas gifts for people who journal
or have a diary
or who are trying to stay positive do
that gratitude thing every day
or get past traumatic experiences
there's always that i journaled for most
of my life to work
through what was going on around me and
being chronically ill
i'm working on a book actually and
i'm getting a lot of the information
from the journals i kept like this one
from marty creative
co uh and i'm getting a lot of my
memories from there
so writing about that so these are
available at
murdy creative.co that's m-u-r-d-y
creative.co codemp
to tell them you came from here and to
get free engravings
i hope you enjoyed this episode if you
do remember to hit subscribe and leave a
review
[Music]
marion 2p welcome to my podcast
thank you very much for having me i have
been
perusing through your book
10 global trends every smart person
should know and
i love it it was actually under my dad's
recommendation that i have you on the
show
um he's been following and i've been
going human progress
on twitter for a very long time um it's
a very positive
twitter account on like most twitter
accounts
so it's kind of cool and now you have
this book which is completely full of
positive things happening in the world
which is something we desperately need
right now given
the circumstances so i'm looking forward
to talking about
some positive things
could hopefully yeah could we start or
could you start just by giving a
brief background about who you are and
what it is that you do
um sure um so i was born uh behind the
iron curtain
in czechoslovakia and
i grew up in south africa i was educated
in britain
i moved to the united states in 2002
where i started working at the cato
institute which is a libertarian think
tank
and i've been with the cato institute
ever since
that time and i really started working
on
economic development for the cato
institute
i was working on transitioning
of economies from communism to
capitalism and also economic development
in sub-saharan africa because of great
interest to me
um where the great differences in wealth
between different countries the the big
question that always fascinated me
partly because i grew up
in a number of different cultures and
i've seen poverty as well as great
wealth
um the the big question that i was
always interested in i
is why are some countries rich and why
are some countries poor
and that's really what occupied me for
the first decade at cato and then
in about 2011 2012 i started thinking
about establishing this website
humanprogress.org
which is really devoted to spreading
not so much a positive as a realistic
message
about the state of the world because
once you start really
looking at these international
statistics
you conclude that the world is in a much
better place than
most people appreciate we we are filled
with these negativity
biases which make us think that the
world is in a much worse shape than it
really is but once you look at the data
you realize
that a lot of things in the world are
going well and
the website has been running for about
eight years and
it's gone through different permutations
but ultimately it's been a success in a
sense that
anecdotal evidence suggests that people
are reading it
uh people are following us and uh some
people even feel better
both about the state of the world and
about their own lives than they used to
yeah so the goal is to spread accurate
information about what's going on in the
world
that's correct so why why do you think
um what we hear is generally
negative about what's going on in the
world i think
a lot of it has to do with human
evolution
uh our species homo sapiens
has been around for about 300 000 years
at the most
but for most of that time life was
actually incredibly difficult
incredibly dangerous and incredibly
short
which meant that
being a pessimist or rather expecting
bad things to happen was actually a very
good survival strategy
if you heard a noise and you overreacted
to it by
jumping away from a from a bush
behind which you heard this noise um
you know if you if you overreact it and
there was nothing
there except for the wind then uh you
you carried on
doing your business but if there was a
lion or a tiger hiding behind that bush
making the noise
and you underreacted to the potential
threat and you thought well
it's probably nothing and you got eaten
then you got weeded out of the gene pool
which is to say that overreaction to
threats
expectation of bad things to happen uh
we were selected for that and the
optimists and people who under-reacted
to threats
were weeded out of the gene pool so
that's just natural evolution
um but there are all sorts of negativity
biases
which uh which have crept into our minds
over the millennia of evolution
such as for example that bad is stronger
than good
we fear losses much more than we
appreciate
gains good things and bad things happen
on different timelines you know it takes
a long time
to get rid of the world of absolute
poverty
uh but it takes a very short time
to plunge hundreds of millions of people
into poverty as they may
as a result of covet endemic
also there is such a thing as
availability heuristic which is that our
minds
pull from the memory file
with greater frequency the most
traumatic events such as for example
seeing an
airplane flying into a skyscraper in
new york in 2001 but
they don't pull out of the memory file
things like for example slipping on a
wet bathroom floor
and dying because we never see anybody
sleeping on a bathroom floor
and dying whereas in fact the data is
clear
your likelihood of dying by sleeping on
a bathroom floor
is much higher than actually dying from
terrorism
so the human mind is on the lookout for
things to fear
and that really prevents us from having
a realistic picture of the world
a realistic sense of what the world and
life is like
okay that makes sense uh in your book
you
you talk about 10 global trends every
smart person should know
so what would you say the main
misconceptions are that we could
try and write during this conversation
well there are there are 78 um different
trends but
the 10 most important ones are things
like for example life expectancy
um you know uh people under appreciate
uh just how recent
the you know how great life expectancy
has been
you know in 1900 which is only 120 years
ago
life expectancy in the richest places in
the world places like the united states
and the united kingdom
was only 50 years or just under 50 years
today global average is 72 years
so that gives you a sense of how how
much longer we are living
partly because fewer babies die in
childbirth
but also because our health care has
gotten much much better
income very few people understand that
until very recently
um world was very poor
what we need to explain is not so much
poverty because poverty was always with
us what we need to explain
as scholars and researchers is why
are we so wealthy today because until
1800
uh pretty much 90 of humanity lived on
two dollars per person per day
and uh today globally people live on
about 40 dollars per person per day
that's adjusted for inflation
so that's another trend uh which is of
interest
is that two dollars ingested for
inflation
correct so um let me just repeat that
so two dollars per person per day
is the level um that that the world bank
the imf and just about anybody in the
world the united nations
we estimate absolute poverty at two
dollars per person per day
if you make much less than two dollars
per person per day
you are probably starving to death so
that
two dollars per person per day is the is
the minimum that's absolute poverty that
is really the boundary between surviving
and seeing the next day
and you know being on the edge having a
50 50 chance that you are not going to
survive
the next day and 90 of humanity lived
like that
until about 1800 and then obviously as a
result of the industrial revolution
uh the west western europe and north
america took off and then later
other countries have caught up and today
the global average
which is to say that somebody living in
um
maybe a place like malaysia today global
average
is 40 per person per day and that's
adjusted for inflation yeah
that is impressive okay wow uh i didn't
realize it was
that bad um you said it
just before the night uh 1900
um this was in about 1800s that would be
two dollars per person per day yeah
i mean the the big change really that
happens in the world
comes in the 19th century the late 18th
century early 19th century
with uh the industrial revolution it
really changes
uh life behind beyond all comprehension
modernity and the level of abundance
which we enjoy is really a question of
the last
200 years so if you think about our
species
as being on earth for the last 300 000
years
modernity and abundance
is really only 0.08
of our time on earth so it's very recent
and
perhaps one reason why so many people
keep on complaining
are ungrateful and are
constantly looking for flaws in in in
the world that we live in today
is because modern life is such a recent
thing
you know as i said 0.08 percent of our
time on earth
yeah my great-grandma told me a story
about
how she could remember seeing the car
the first time
she lived in northern canada but she
described it as a giant monster coming
through the forest because they've never
seen a car before
so just i guess all that experience now
that
is new grandparents grandparents have
their uses
uh one of my uh one of my grandmothers
um grew up during the second world war
and they didn't have any food so she
would insist that i eat
everything because you know she
constantly expected another war to come
she remembered starvation
in europe uh with uh in in her own
lifetime my other grandmother
insisted that i learn how to sew because
uh it was inconceivable for her to throw
away socks
if they had a hole in them our
grandmothers just simply
fixed those things they wouldn't they
wouldn't think about
throwing away clothes just because it
had holes in it
yeah and i suppose i in especially in
certain
parts of europe um that kind of life is
more recent than say north america
although it's not
it's not that much more recent but it's
fairly recent especially if you were
behind the
wall right well thankfully in
in north america we didn't have uh the
sort of slaughter that europe has gone
through
during the 20th century yeah yeah yeah
uh okay so one of the things we hear
about all the time about how
the world is doomed is climate change
so what's your opinion on climate change
i know there was a bit in your book
about
forests which i was very surprised about
so i thought you could talk a little bit
about
that sure so um
let's start with the trends that we have
identified which is
which we call the greening of the planet
co2 is plant food
anybody who's gone to high school and
has learned about
um about
about uh plants uh and
and co2 and how plants survive and how
they grow understands
that that co2 is plant food and so
more co2 in the atmosphere also means
that vegetation is growing
there is vegetation is more luscious we
have more greening of the planet more
trees and so forth so between 1982
and 2016 the planet has greened
added greenery the size of alaska and
montana combined
so that's a cool trend it means that uh
you know the worries that we had
in the 1980s for example i remember
there were worries that sahara was going
to continue to grow
until it was going to consume the entire
african continent so that obviously
hasn't happened
and that brings me to the second part of
your question which was
uh climate change before i talk about
climate change
i just want to mention that climate
change is not the first
global concern that humanity has had
i remember things like concern over the
ozone layer
concern over acidic
rain or acid rain i remember concerns
about desertification
concern about running out of water
running out of oil
concerns over uh things like sex change
fish and sperm counts falling and god
knows what else
and one by one they have all gone away
some of it happened because those were
not
worries in the first place the things
just weren't happening that people
thought were happening
but other things happen because humanity
has come up with solutions to problems
and i think that when it comes to
climate change
what used to be called until yesterday
global warming
um we are going to hopefully we are
going to come up with solutions to that
um this is a large subject but i i do
want to say a few things on that
um i think that the debate has moved on
dramatically from say 10 years ago
very few people now doubt that some form
of global warming is happening the world
is warming a little bit
uh most people accept that climate
change is happening
in fact climate has been changing since
the planet was born and will continue to
go changing until
the sun explodes and fries all of us so
so climate change is happening and there
are two ways
in which humanity is proposing to
address climate change on the one hand
are people who are saying that we should
limit
population growth and we should limit
consumption of resources
which is to say that prosperity and
economic growth
and more people who can afford things
and use things and consume things
is bad because it will destroy the
planet so these are what i would call
restrictionists they want to restrict
global growth they want to restrict
global consumption in hope
that as a result of that decrease in
consumption you are going to have
less climate change and in fact you
could see
on cnn bbc and many other places
people basically saying that look what
kovid has
has has resulted in covet has resulted
in dramatic declines
in co2 emissions it has the you know
this is the way to go
i don't think this is the way to go i
think that much of humanity
is at the breaking point as a result of
the lockdowns and i don't think that
many people except for greater thundberg
think that human future should consist
of being locked up in your apartment
for six months of the year not being
able to travel
visit your family and so on and so forth
so what i'm a part of
is that second half of humans who
believes that
climate change should be addressed
through technological change
and adaptation let's take adaptation
first
one third of holland is under water
um meaning uh lies underwater or under
the water level which is to say that for
the last 500 years
uh the dutch have been drying uh
the atlantic and carving out of the
atlantic of the north sea
more and more territory to expand the
netherlands
and they have done so when they were
extraordinarily poor by today's
standards there is absolutely no reason
why rich countries today cannot cope
with rising sea levels which will happen
uh
in incremental bits of the next number
of decades
there is no reason why they couldn't do
what the dutch have done for or 500
years ago so that's adaptation
and then comes uh technological change
and here i would say
that it would be beneficial probably on
balance
if we switched to non-co2 fuels
the the the most important one of which
we have known about for 75 years and
that's nuclear
which produces plenty of energy without
spewing any co2 into the atmosphere
and which can power the entire humanity
and that should be our next step
or rather the immediate step more
nuclear power
um and in the medium to long-term future
maybe we can
maybe we can really find a a fusion
reactor so so currently nuclear
power is fission it breaks up uh atoms
but if we can create nuclear fusion
which combines
atoms it will be even safer and
that could be that could be an answer to
producing energy without co2
i wanted to get a nuclear physicist or
someone who does nuclear energy on the
podcast because i had
um bjorn longer gone um a couple of
months ago
and she talked about nuclear power a
little bit and how that was the way to
go
he also mentioned that if the water
rises people probably won't be standing
at the edge slowly drowning while that
happens
well there's just one more thing i want
to say about nuclear and that is that i
do realize of course that nuclear is not
100
safe nothing in life is 100 safe
but if you compare how many people
around the world
die due to indoor
smoke you know when they don't have
electricity but they have to burn
coal and dung in africa for example
in order to cook their food and they get
they get lung cancer
or or what have you and they die
millions of people
die uh because they don't have access to
plentiful energy
every year um you know and
and just because the communists were so
completely inept and produced the
disaster in chernobyl
doesn't mean that every single nuclear
power station out there
is as badly built and poorly run
as chernobyl was so you know
we keep on improving our technology all
the time
and uh nuclear really is
in my view the the answer to our
immediate problems
um with the more recent disaster in
japan
um they found out there were a bunch of
mistakes made there too right
that's correct so first thing to
remember about fukushima that
to my knowledge nobody has died from
radiation in fukushima
okay um i think the fatality is still
zero
so that's something to remember that
even though it was a massive disaster it
did not result in the kind of chernobyl
style
irradiation and that's that's that bell
russia and ukraine have experienced in
the 1980s and
1990s second thing is yes the way design
flaws um if memory serves a right
uh the the the the
the power system to power the coolant
uh was actually not secure
um i think that the the fuel uh for the
for for the auxiliary power which would
have powered water which would have
enabled water to cool down these
reactors
was actually not properly secure and was
then wiped out during the tsunami
uh but of course one silver lining
of the fukushima disaster is that now we
know
that in future designs of nuclear
reactors we have to make sure that the
power source
for the water coolant has to be secure
in many ways of course humanity
improves its technical ability its
technical understanding
precisely because it encounters problems
it is because what happened with covet
that we have discovered
all the different ways in which western
societies are not prepared for pandemics
uh all the different ways in which uh
science and research were lagging behind
and when the next pandemic happens 20 30
100 years from now
the lessons that we will learn through
covet will be applied to those things
it's very difficult to think about
anything in human life any learning
experience which doesn't come from
adversity which doesn't come from some
sort of a disaster it's usually
um some sort of a challenge a disaster a
catastrophe from which people learn
otherwise
they wouldn't really have an incentive
to learn very much would they
no not at all maybe that's why people
who haven't been through anything
tough or somewhat annoying to be around
that's very true okay
uh how about how about this uh
overpopulation thing you hear about all
the time that we're going to
read so much that we won't have any food
we'll
over populate the planet destroy it that
way
how much of that is true boy that's
another very big subject so
the first thing to remember is that
total fertility rates are collapsing
around the world
um in order to keep population stable
uh an average woman in the world has to
have 2.1
babies per lifetime so 2.1
is the replacement scenario in
why isn't it just two because you you
you assume that some babies will die
okay
during before they reach adulthood uh
or or old age you know some will die in
childhood
then due to accidents and so forth so so
2.1
is the replacement rate and
those are collapsing in most of the
world except in africa so in places like
the czech republic in slovakia where i'm
from
um total fertility rate per woman is
something like 1.4 1.3
so you know japan is below replacement
level
most countries without immigration are
below replacement level in
in the developed world okay which
means that all the best research
including a recent study in landsat
that you will be familiar with found
that
there will be a leveling off of
population in about 2060 2070
and then population will decline so
by 2100 in 80 years time
there will either be nine sorry
uh right now there are 7.8 billion
people
in the world today there are 7.8 billion
people in the world by 2100
there is even either going to be 8.8 or
6.8 billion people
so either we are going to have a
slightly more or slightly less
uh people in the world than today but
there is going to be that curve we are
going to peak at about 10 billion and
then it's going to decline to either 9
billion or 7 billion depending
on you know it's very difficult to
prognosticate 80 years hence
but there's no reason to suspect that
total fertility rates for women around
the world are going to skyrocket
in the future because um
what we observe is that as women get
educated and as they
enter the workplace they have fewer and
fewer babies and of course the whole
world is improving economically and more
and more women are entering in the work
work workplace even in developing
countries
as a result of which their uh their
opportunity costs are rising so that's
just a very fancy economics phrase for
saying
that if a woman stays at home uh taking
care of the children her opportunity
cost
um is is is
if the woman foregoes employment and
making money
uh because she can because she has job
opportunities
her opportunity cost of staying at home
increases
in other words when women are given a
chance of going to employment and making
money they prefer it
over staying at home taking care of
children now of course as your father
would know and pointed out a number of
times and i agree with that completely
if women do decide to stay at home and
take care of children there's absolutely
nothing wrong
with that all i'm saying is that
uh there seems to be a general trend
that
as countries become richer and women get
education they they start having fewer
babies and they
they many of them hope to go to work
so the first thing to point out about
population growth is that it's not going
to continue to
extend indefinitely there's going to be
a peak in about 20 60
70 and then it's going to decline
secondly
it's not necessarily clear that having
fewer people around is a good thing
and that's because people are the only
generators of
ideas which is to say that if you
believe like i do
that ideas is what drives
technological progress forward then you
want to have more people having those
ideas it is much easier to imagine a
genius
emerging from a population of 10 billion
people who will know how to cure cancer
than from a population of 100 people
simply the mathematics of it means
that the larger population you have the
more likely you are ahead
the geniuses at the top end
of the intellectual achievement will be
able to
produce solutions to
fusion and fission and cancer
and god knows what else so having fewer
people is not necessarily a good thing
and and i'm not particularly concerned
about population even though
the trends are very clear and the final
thing let me
talk about food um
according to the united states
department of agriculture
on average people should consume about 2
000 calories per person per day now
obviously there are huge differences
between
very active males say i don't know
somebody who is working in construction
and
an elderly woman in a retirement home
who needs many fewer than 2 000 calories
but on average
you want your country to have access to
at least 2 000 calories
per person per day today in sub-saharan
africa
supply of calories per person per day is
almost
2500. so
so that means that famines
have basically disappeared from the
world outside of war zones or where
countries are really badly managed
like zimbabwe for example or
whether you have wars like yemen but in
normally run countries right now as a
general rule
there are more calories available than
are strictly speaking
necessary and that includes the world's
poorest continent which is
africa wow that's great so as long as
it's spread out properly and not
hoarded by some you know a dictator or
something like that
then things are going pretty well yes
and
you know there can always be localized
food shortages
you know maybe you have a village
which which has been struck by
i don't know a tornado or something like
that or a town
but here again thank god we live in
today's world in modernity because those
people can use their cell phones
to call people for help and we can
deliver
help including food to any part of the
world
via fast and reliable transport systems
which
wasn't really available to people even
as
early as 100 years ago
yeah so so you've written this book
about and i would say
it's realistic but it is positive but
the positive changes in the world
uh what are the things we should
actually be concerned about
well one of my big ones
is actually freedom of speech
one of the trends that we have in the
book
is called freedom of the press and you
know freedom of the press freedom of
speech that
you know they're the same they're in the
same family of concerns
and interestingly enough um freedom of
the press in the world is lower than
what it was
was lower in the 90 in 2010s
than it was in 2040s
now the reason why we included that
trend
in the book is because freedom of the
press today
is much higher than it was in the 70s
and the 80s
but the trend is the trend was like this
and now it's the freedom of the press is
decreasing
okay so it has increased tremendously
between from the 70s
but now it's on the decrease again and
that's something so freedom of the press
and freedom of speech is something that
concerns me for a number of reasons one
is
that if you don't have freedom of the
press and freedom of speech
it is very difficult to figure out when
a society is going in the wrong
direction
so the only way that you can know
whether your society is doing something
right
is if uh if people are allowed to
criticize
if they are if they are allowed to speak
um
but if there is no criticism if you are
not allowed to criticize
the the orthodoxy then of course
you cannot reverse your course and you
are hurtling toward the precipice
the second thing is that freedom of
speech and freedom of press
are absolutely necessary for
technological scientific and medical
progress
if you are not going to be able to come
up with ideas
put those ideas down on paper share
those ideas
research those ideas then
then you cannot have much progress and
and
you know today people may feel
that freedom of speech is only
disappearing from certain
um deeply political areas
but that's not true freedom of speech is
also disappearing from
a branch of sciences like uh like
biology
uh like genetics and so on and so forth
um
what's happening with genetics well
research on genetic differences between
individuals but
between groups of people is actually
being um
being consigned to uh
the uh or rather is being being frowned
upon and is being restricted
um because because uh uh
humanity does have a long and
unfortunate history
uh with racism unfortunately
genetics is also very important in
identifying for example
different receptors for drugs which may
be necessary in order to cure people so
we know that different groups of people
uh have different prevalences of
different diseases
there are certain diseases which are
much more prevalent in
amongst the jewish community there are
certain diseases
which befall south asians uh much
more than they befall other people um
obesity uh is a much greater problem
amongst the pacific
um uh pacific
pacific islanders uh than in other parts
of the world
and so we want to actually know
uh about genetic differences uh between
people
so that we can in large part so that we
can
tailor our medical research
uh towards helping them uh not all drugs
are going to be working
uh in the same way for for different
people and and
that's something um that we really don't
want to
get away from that's really not
something that we want to lose just
because
um just because research into in into
into genes and genetic differences is
something which is right now politically
incorrect
and very politically sensitive okay i
didn't
i haven't thought about that a lot so
that that is that is concerning
um would you know whether or not in uh
say the ussr
where their what political correctness
was definitely there
but they also had quite a bit of
innovation did they ever
limit scientific work based on
kind of what we're seeing here now oh
certainly
um during the stalin era which was a
very long time between 1927 and 1953
when the world's greatest mass murderer
eventually
died the soviets
banned research into genetics
so instead of relying on on
genes as we understand them they had
their own pseudoscience
of a man called lisenko
lisenko believed that genes were not
necessarily passed down through
generations
uh but that you could affect uh
performance of people uh but also
also also um also crops
through um through through environmental
uh changes so for example they would
play a music
piano to uh to things like
crops of wheat and things like that
expecting
that those would grow higher if
or more plentiful if you if you do that
sort of thing and uh it was absolutely
crazy but the point is that there was
pseudoscience pursued in the soviet
union
um lissanko ism was a perfect example of
that
playing pianos for the weed um
and whilst it is true that the soviet
union has
accomplished some very big successes
especially in military technology and
with german help missile technology
it is not true that the soviet union was
anywhere close to
the american or western european
production of technological
progress in fact one of the reasons why
the soviet union collapsed
is precisely because it wasn't uh
technologically advanced it was very
clear to the soviet rulers
by the 1970s and 1980s that they were
falling very deeply behind
the west when it comes to technological
uh technological advances and
technological breakthrough
and that was partly because they didn't
have freedom of speech
uh freedom of the press freedom of
association but it was also partly
because
the incentives were misaligned uh
you know you couldn't tap private
capital
in order to build a uh
you know spacex or
microsoft or whatever it had to go
through
centrally planned allocation of capital
and for a variety of reasons the soviet
union was actually
not very good at producing technological
research except for
weaponry okay okay that that makes sense
if you're not allowed to
build things privately i mean how else
would well the soviet union had
the largest number of doctors
per per thousand people and yet
its uh life expectancy was
over 10 years lower than in the united
states even though they had many more
doctors
they had many more engineers than the
united states
um and yet they weren't able to build
roads and railways uh
to to to the same level of um
of of efficiency and uh and
and speed and reliability as people in
the west
um they they didn't have any stock
brokers
uh and yet uh and yet uh and and yet
maybe that that is what they
should have had instead all those
numbers of
of uh engineers and um
and doctors and so forth they didn't
have any way
to evaluate the the price mechanism
they didn't have any way to deal with
the price system and
they didn't have capitals and they
didn't have free market that's why they
collapsed
so you mentioned that the freedom of
press right now is similar to what it
was
here in the 70s or 80s that's what you
said no no
no what i meant to say was that um
freedom of the press today is lower than
what it was
in the 20 ortiz meaning from 2000 to
2010
it's lower but it is higher than it was
in the 70s and the 80s
so we have seen an increase in freedom
of the press from 1970 to about
2010 and now we are starting to see a
decline
but because the decline is not as big as
where it was in the 70s we still
included the trend okay that's what i
meant
do you think that decline is going to
continue
well um i i suppose that very much
depends
on on all of us uh and
what we do i mean your father obviously
uh was a great hero to to many people
for standing up against speech codes
and i think that more and more people
are fed up
with political correctness i think that
we have probably seen
peak political correctness around
2015-16
um and now
or at least that's when we saw the the
greatest flourishing of it i don't
know whether we have less political
correctness today
bigger pattern i don't think so i think
it's way worse
you think it's it's gotten worse um yeah
that may well be true um but
um but um
certainly it's not very helpful
that some of the world's greatest um
uh platforms uh for sharing of news and
uh are are now engaged in
in censorship i suspect that what will
happen
is that alternatives to twitter google
and facebook will emerge and that the
monopoly power
of these media platforms will actually
decline
um you know i remember in the early
2000s
when when microsoft
microsoft was being was being um
had to face a lawsuit um because of what
of its supposed monopoly uh position
in the market and by the time the
lawsuit came to an end
microsoft had so many different
competitors
that the issue became mute and and it is
very difficult to imagine within a free
market system
that a monopoly position of twitter and
facebook and google
will persist forever so i'm hoping that
there will be a technological solution
to the monopoly power of these companies
and i'm also hoping that more and more
people will simply refuse to
um to to stay silent
and will start speaking out i mean your
father obviously has inspired a lot of
people to speak out
and um i i hope that that continues
but i can't be sure he'll be back he'll
come back
hopefully inspire some more people maybe
that'll help
i'm hoping it'll help okay back to you
back to more positive stuff i told
people this was going to be positive and
then
i found out that i had a good chance of
dying by slipping on my bathroom floor
so how about iq
you talk about iq in your book and i i
i think my dad had told me about this
and i'd forgotten but i think it'd be
interesting to talk about
what are the trends in iq trend number
21.
there we go by the way the book the book
is designed in this way for a reason
is that on one side you have the charts
which are very prettily designed
and on the other side you've got a
little bit of text you know 300 to 500
words describing and what is happening
in that chart
and so it's it's supposed to be so that
no matter where you open it
you are going to learn something about
one trend
and in this particular case what it
shows that from 2000
from 1909
to 2013 which is to say over a course of
about 100 years
uh cumulatively we have added about 30
iq
points that's a crazy amount two
standard deviations
so that's obviously a massive uh
massive improvement and some people call
this the flynn effect
in in recent years we have seen
that the flynn effect stopped happening
in some advanced western european
countries in other words they reached a
certain
level they kept on adding to their iq
scores and then it leveled off
okay but but in in other places in the
world
uh iqs continue to increase now the big
question obviously there is
whether there is some sort of a hard
limit on
the average iq uh and whether all
countries
as they improve their uh health and
nutrition will eventually reach that
plateau that western european countries
have reached and then it will level up
or whether it's simply as a pause or
bad measurement and iqs continue to
increase
in in western europe as they have up to
this point
one of the things to remember about the
increase in iq
points which is to say 30 points between
1909
and 2013 is that it is global average
so that doesn't mean that in all
countries around the world
uh iqs have risen
by 30 points um you know
especially in countries which uh which
where people already scored very high
uh that score would have in part
reflected the fact that those people had
very good nutrition a very good
education
access to all sorts of opportunities
that people in other parts of the world
didn't however
as previously backward parts of the
world as
underdeveloped countries as very poor
countries
got better health and better education
and better
nutrition they were able to
then increase their iq scores
again on average uh to a level
where they would have been if their
nutrition education and healthcare were
were better so once again when it comes
to a discussion
of intelligence and iq points it's
incredibly important to emphasize
that we are not talking about uh
in that we are talking about um
about averages and in this particular
trend what we are talking about
is a global average where the increase
in iq points would have been
disproportionately affected
by uh by by countries that have gained
some level of of better life
uh in the last 50 60 70 years
okay that completely makes sense so
places where people were
starving let's say probably couldn't
afford to give as much nutrition to
their brain as
places that weren't starving that makes
sense
precisely do you think given the amount
of opportunity
now uh it's easier for people
who are lucky enough to be hired to have
a higher iq
do you think it's easier for them to
kind of show that they have a higher iq
or to produce more
or to accomplish more than it was say
100 years ago
yes i think so because
because 100 years ago if you were
an intelligent child in say sub-saharan
africa or south asia
your chances of discovering something
interesting something worthwhile your
your ability
to to improve your life and and those of
your fellow human beings was very
limited
by a basic lack of opportunities so
you know a hundred years ago vast
chunks of humanity pretty much all of
africa most of latin america pretty much
all of asia
you know people there didn't have any
opportunity so even children which would
have been born
with higher than average intelligence
wouldn't be able to do much with it
whereas today if you have higher than
average intelligence
uh there are all sorts of things which
are open to you you can work remotely
even from uh you know um from
even in africa even in asia you can work
remotely you can apply
yourself you have access to the entirety
of human knowledge
on the internet so that's another bonus
and of course
if you can show that you have above
average intelligence
then you are going to probably be hired
uh
by somebody in the united states or in
china and uh you're going to be a uh
you're going to be an
immigrant um where you can apply your
your your intelligence um
in a place which is more appreciative
than maybe
than than your native land yeah that's
something i think people really forget
how much opportunity there is even just
with the internet you can learn
almost not anything but you can learn
more than you could
possibly want to in a lifetime in any
type of niche just from going online and
a lot of it is
free which is incredible compared to
everything else humanity's experience
since we've been around
and that kind of opportunity is insane
that's right
we should be grateful for that yeah
uh it i mean it's helped me a lot with
like autoimmune
issues i was able to go online and read
free research papers
right like thousands of them so yeah
thank goodness for that even though the
internet has some downsides
that's the amount of information on
there it's amazing
uh okay i had a couple of other ones i
wanted to cover
um let me think
okay
and so this was a question actually you
mentioned it earlier you said
the lifespan of people
it used to be 50 what year was that in
for the richest people in the world it
was 50 in 1900
is the reason it was so much lower
because there was so much infant
mortality
to a lesser extent than it used to be
the case so remember that
throughout the history of our species
let's say the last
well let's take it back to the
agricultural revolution 12 000 years ago
as far as we can tell uh human life
expectancy until 1800 was about 25 to 30
years
how do we know that does that imperial
skeletons um you know we can we can we
can date skeletons for example
um and that was that was partly driven
uh by that was in large part driven by
a huge child mortality and infant
mortality
it doesn't mean average life expectancy
doesn't mean that once you reach 25 or
30 you're just going to drop dead
it just means that once you account for
all the dead babies
life expectancy of people who were born
alive
was about 25 to 30 years but once you
once you
lift to about five and longer
your likelihood of living to 50 or 60
improved
dramatically okay so so let's say for
the last 12 000 years
most of the low life expectancy was
driven
by uh high infant mortality
but by 1900 in europe and in north
america which are the richest parts of
the world
which were the richest parts of the
world back then and still are
um the
the life expectancy of 50 was not
primarily
impacted by the number of infants who
died
still much higher number of infants died
than is the case today
but life expectancy was limited by a
very primitive state
of of human healthcare
a very inferior understanding of science
pathogens and things like that let me
give you one example
calvin coolidge's son
calvin coolidge was the president of the
united states in my view the greatest
president of the united states between
1920 and 1928
and in 1927 or 26
he was playing tennis on
on the tennis court at the white house
and he was playing barefooted and he
developed a blister
which got infected and an
infection set in which killed the boy
within days two years later
fleming discovered antibiotics okay
but here is the case of the president's
son who dies from an
infected blister only 100 years ago
so wow so in the early 1900s
what really kept the human population at
sorry the richest people from living
much
longer than 50 on average was really the
fact that
medicine was still incredibly primitive
and science was
uh still very inferior um um
again as i said we didn't get
antibiotics until uh
until fleming discovery in 1928 so
that's something
yeah yeah of course
[Music]
there's like i i talk a lot about the
problems of having too much
antibiotics and how that can be a
problem
but the fact that they're around now and
weren't yeah
means you can survive from having an
infected blister yeah
wow what a way to go that must have not
have been fun too
that's rough absolutely horrific and the
war and human history is
replete with tremendous amount of how
heartbreaks um women seeing their
children
yeah die left and right you know it was
not a pleasant
life part of the reason why i suspect
that that
uh people were much more religious in
the past was precisely because they had
to deal with the pain
and you know we're expecting to be
rejoined with their little ones
in in the afterlife my god this is way
less positive well at least that's not
that's not around as much yeah i can't
imagine
going through something like i have a
kid going through a pregnancy
breastfeeding and then having
something wipe out two of your kids when
it
when in 1750 uh the second half of the
18th century
um infant mortality in in sweden uh
was 50 so that gives you a sense of
you know where we were oh brutal and
that was
like bacterial and viral
yeah right oh all sorts of things of
course women women died in childbirth
much more frequently than they do now um
for a variety of things uh have you seen
um
what was that what was that serious that
british series
uh downton abbey uh the the daughter of
the earl
dies from preeclampsia is that eclampsia
yeah of course they had no idea what was
happening around them
um you know again
how lucky we are even in the middle of
the coveted pandemic
that within days of discovering this
quote
unquote pneumonia in china we were able
to break down the genetic code of this
virus and then name it and send samples
all over the world
um you know until 200 years ago
people had no idea what they were dying
of they they they couldn't they
didn't even have a name yeah who was it
you actually might know this
there was some doctor who was he was
wondering why there was
such a high infection rate after after
pregnancy
and he realized he hadn't been washing
he was i think he was a kind
guy who came up with germ theory i think
but i could be wrong and he noticed he
wasn't washing his hands when he went in
between
patients and he was spreading infections
yes you've got it right his uh his name
was
sommelweis um i think and he was a
hungarian
yeah yeah and and um
he did partly because the world wouldn't
accept his discovery
and he got he got tremendously
discouraged by that
even though so basically what happened
was that
people generally were much filthier in
the past
and washing of hands was not
the top of their priority uh partly
because they had no idea
that germs uh pathogens
uh were spread through uh
these tiny little invisible monsters
which live
at the end of your fingertips
well precisely not only didn't people
people didn't have you know
antiseptics and people didn't have uh
bacteria killing soap
uh people just didn't wash their hands
in the first place which means that if
you went
to the toilet or if you if you if you
worked your entire day in the fields
with manure you went home
and you ate with those same hands food
which then gave you gastrointestinal
problems like you cannot possibly
imagine
well anyway there was another reason why
doctors specifically didn't wash their
hands and their clothes
and that was that the gorier and
bloodier your clothes wear
no the the more you are advertising to
the world that you were a doctor in
demand
okay so uh
only a doctor was covered in blood and
gore was a really good doctor right
yeah so anyway in in this hospital that
summerwise was at
um doctors would perform autopsies and
then they would go deliver babies
or check out uh women's private parts
and they would deliver all sorts of
horrible things to the woman's body
infecting the woman's body and so on and
so forth
and some always realized that uh that
this
didn't have to be so and so he was a
precursor to the germ theory of
of uh germ theory which was then proved
by pasteur
later like 20 years later yeah yeah okay
okay i don't know where i read that
online but uh
interesting okay we're out of time
can you tell that was really fun uh
thank you very much for coming on
can you let everyone know where they can
find you
well i'm a senior fellow at the cato
institute which is a libertarian
non-partisan think tank non-profit think
tank
in washington dc and
i run a website called
humanprogress.org we are an autonomous
part of the cato institute
and humanprogress.org you can you can
see us online you can follow us on
twitter
facebook and instagram and goodness
knows what else
so please do that and if you get a
chance um
do buy this book that we have just
bought
i i don't just say it out of pecuniary
reasons
but if you want to spread a little bit
of optimism a little bit of joy
and put an end to this
miserable year in in a more optimistic
style
then get yourself a book um show it to
your friends or just let it lie
on on the living room table and when
people open it your guests open it it
may spark an interesting conversation so
let's hope for that uh hopefully well i
agree it's a very good
coffee table book specifically because
like you said
you can just open it and it gives you
like a story on one page a graph
and a little you know whatever statistic
you're looking at
so it's a great coffee table book it's
probably my favorite coffee would work
um and it's very kind of you thank you
oh no i know it is it's really cool
so thank you very much for coming on um
and i will
talk to you later thank you very much
you